good morning John gosh do I love pizza
Miss why why do I love pizza so much
because I get to do stuff I would never
normally do on this channel like for
example play Trombone champ it has been
a long time since I've done a let's play
I hope I'm still capable of it not
enough disk space to record
still some glitches to work out okay I
just deleted 12 gigabytes of stuff I'm
recording now so trombone champ if you
hadn't heard about it is like Guitar
Hero built with trombones and it's
absolutely unhinged I played a very tiny
bit yesterday I'm going to start out
with John with one of your favorites
it's all Lang Syne the facts by the way
are wrong I learned that early let's go
you gotta concentrate
it came at me fast it did not give you a
lot of time to prepare for this
[Music]
Peppa Pig
[Music]
all right hey oh my God I oh almost my
forearm hurts from sitting the space bar
I could not relax and now you have to
choose what you're going to do next I
don't I don't know what this song is
let's see if it's good alarm just went
off and I'm wondering if I'm gonna miss
a meeting right now no
oh God oh God
[Music]
oh I have for this one everything I know
about classical music I learned from
trombone Jam
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel like I kind of got I got it
together there at the end
let's see it really does do a number on
the old forearm though
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm killing it
[Music]
[Music]
ha ha ha ha ha ha
I feel like I was better than the last
time
and it was
barely let's go ahead and see what I'm
really made of
[Music]
vastly overestimated viabilities
[Music]
Peppa Peppa
[Music]
pretty bad pretty bad
I got to see the
that's astounding John everyone thank
you for pizza Miss without which I would
not have a chance to get this goofy I
will see you tomorrow and not through a
computer screen exciting